les produits surgelés largement
plébiscité ces derniers mois avec le
confinement
leurs ventes ont augmenté + 30 % en mars
et en avril en france
c'est au début des années 60 que les
surgelés ont fait leur apparition et les
produits surgelés ne sont plus à
présenter tout le monde en a dégusté ou
tout au moins on a entendu parler à
cette époque les modes de consommation
et d'alimentation commence à changer les
supermarchés se multiplient la
nourriture industrielle se développent
et le poisson pané surgelés débarque
dans la cuisine des français servir
arrosez n'a jus de citrouille de beurre
fondu persillé et vous pouvez
l'accompagner d'une sauce tomate
aromatisés des plats rapides et
efficaces
un moyen pour les femmes de passer moins
de temps derrière les fourneaux et
certaines ne se font pas prier
oui on achète presse qu'est ce que vous
achetez dans les productions et poisson
[Musique]
des légumes à la fin des années 60
l'intérêt pour les surgelés est certain
mais à l'échelle nationale leur
consommation est encore timide
les raisons les congélateurs sont encore
rares dans les foyers et certains
français s'interrogent encore sur la
qualité de ses produits au début des
années 70
non et pourquoi est ce que c'est pour
preuve alors pour convaincre les plus
réticents les industriels vont à leur
rencontre des salons et des réunions
d'information sur les surgelés sont
organisées dans toute la france pour les
haricots verts ou sortez vos haricots
verts surgelés de votre congélateur
voulait trempé tout de suite dans l'eau
bouillante et vous les laissez cuire 10
minutes comme d'autres haricots verts
l'initiative portera ses fruits
à la fin des années soixante dix
l'industrie des produits surgelés est en
plein essor la consommation augmente
tous les ans de 15 à 20% et a doublé
depuis 1964 un succès attribué aussi à
la généralisation des congélateurs à
l'émergence des enseignes spécialisées
et au développement des places
industriel surgelés dans les années 80
la croissance de l'industrie du surgelé
se confirme
en 1981 les français consommaient près
de 10 kg de produits surgelés par
personne et par an ces dernières années
malgré les scandales sanitaires et les
remises en question diététique des
produits surgelés
le marché tient le cap avec un chiffre
d'affaires estimé à 9 milliards d'euros
[Musique]